Guten Tag, mein Name ist Shingu Jü. Ich bin Erstenherr und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, bin ich.
Okay, so als benötige ich einmal ein paar Personen hier dazwischen zu Ihnen. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Patrick Grundmann.
Patrick Grundmann. Können Sie mir hier vor und nachnamen, wo ich probiere?
Ja, Patrick schreibt sich P, A, T, R, I, C, K. Patrick und Grundmann, G, R, U, N, D, M, A, N, N. Grundmann.
Okay, Herr Grundmann, wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Patrick Grundmann, ich bin 65 Jahre.
Und wie groß und wie schwer sind Sie?
1,84 Meter groß und 96 Kilogramm schwer.
Und was fühlst Sie sonst, Herr Grundmann?
ungefähr Bauchschmerzen und die werden aber immer schlimmer.
Die haben langsam angefangen und werden jetzt immer schlimmer und das
halte ich nicht mehr aus. Deswegen komme ich jetzt zu Ihnen in die Klinik.
Okay.
Können Sie am Ende des Geschenks
ihr Schmerz nicht anhalten oder brauchen Sie im Sofort eine Schmerz mit?
Nein, ich kann es im Augenblick noch aushalten.
Okay, das ist sehr gut.
Können Sie mir sagen, wo genau diese Schmerzen haben?
Also so angefangen haben die Schmerzen links vom Bauchnabel, auf der linken Seite vom Bauchnabel,
aber inzwischen tut der ganze Bauch weh.
Okay.
Können Sie diese Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Zum Beispiel, Dumf, Stehend, Brennend, Odakolikartik?
Die Schmerzen sind mehr dumpf und auch krampfartig, aber mehr dumpf.
Also sie sind immer da.
Okay.
Und wie ist die Schmerz von Nuul bis Stehend?
Wobei Nuul keine Schmerzen, Stehend z.T.
Sieben bis acht.
Nein, Fieber habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Habt ihr Übelkeit oder Erbrechung?
Ja, seit einigen Stunden habe ich Übelkeit und ich habe auch schon zweimal jetzt erbrochen in den letzten Stunden.
Habt ihr Durchfall?
Nein, Durchfall habe ich nicht.
Okay. Hatten Sie diese Beschwerden früher schon einmal oder ist das erst einmal?
Nein, so etwas habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Habt ihr wie verstopft?
Nein, ich habe normalerweise immer regelmäßig Stuhlgang.
Jetzt, seitdem ich die Schmerzen habe, habe ich glaube ich gar keinen Stuhlgang mehr gehabt.
Aber ich habe auch kaum mehr etwas gegessen, weil mir ja übel war und ich habe keinen Appetit gehabt, seitdem die Schmerzen angefangen haben.
Okay.
Und haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden?
Mir ist übel, ich habe diese Schmerzen und nein, sonst habe ich im Augenblick keine anderen Schmerzen, aber das ist schon genug, weil das so weh tut.
Okay. Und diese Schmerzen ist immer noch ungenannt, dann habe ich ja im ganzen Bauch inzwischen begonnen.
Begonnen hat es links vom Nabel, auf der linken Seite vom Nabel, mehr auf der linken Seite im Bauch, da hat es begonnen, da war plötzlich dieser Schmerz und inzwischen tut aber der ganze Bauch weh.
Okay. Okay, herr Guntmann, haben Sie in letzterseits ab oder zu genommen?
Nein, ich habe mein Gewicht gehalten.
Okay.
Und können Sie gut schlafen?
Normalerweise kann ich ganz gut schlafen, aber in den letzten zwei Nächten, als ich seitdem ich die Schmerzen habe, habe ich nicht gut geschlafen.
Haben Sie nachts Schweiß oder Schweizer Brust?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Und haben Sie gegen etwas Allergien oder Unfallzwecklichkeit?
Nein, das ist mir nicht bekannt.
Und leider Sie an chronischer Erkrankung von deinen Ehe-Geräuschen?
Ja, ich habe hohen Blutdruck, seit ungefähr acht Jahren, da nehme ich auch Medikamente ein.
Und ich habe hohe Scholesterin, da nehme ich auch ungefähr seit fünf Jahren ein Medikament ein.
Ja, und dann habe ich Herzrhythmusstörungen, seit drei Jahren, da wurde eine Katheterbehandlung gemacht.
Und damit sollte der Herzrhythmus, wie es hieß, immer wieder in seinen alten Rhythmus gebracht werden, das Herz, aber das war nicht erfolgreich.
Und dann muss ich seitdem auch eine Tablette nehmen gegen Blutgerinzel.
Okay.
Und zwar kann Medikament sein, aber wie ein?
Ich nehme einmal ein für den Blutdruck, das heißt Candesatan.
Wie viele Medikament?
Da hinter steht acht, da nehme ich eine Tablette morgens und eine abends.
Da nehme ich noch Bisoprolol, da hinter steht fünf, da nehme ich auch eine morgens und eine abends.
Okay.
Da nehme ich noch zur Senkung von dem Cholesterin, das Mittel heißt Moment Simvastatin.
Da hinter steht 20, da nehme ich eine Tablette abends.
Und für die Blutgerinnung oder gegen ein Blutgerinsel heißt das Mittel Lixiana.
Lixiana, da hinter steht 60, da nehme ich eine Tablette morgens.
Okay.
Okay, Herr Gutmann, Sie haben uns schon gesagt, da wie eine Herzrhythmus hat.
Ja, und ausgerechnet von Bundesli Operis?
Ja, also der Herzkatheter war, weil ich diese Rhythmusstörung hatte oder habe.
Und da hat man gesagt, mit einem Herzkatheter kann man eine Stelle am Herzen finden
und die mit Kälte behandeln.
Und dann kann es sein, dass das Herz wieder in seinen alten Rhythmus kommt.
Ja.
Und das war aber nicht erfolgreich.
Sie haben diese Stelle nicht gut gefunden und seitdem habe ich diese Rhythmusstörungen
und muss eben dieses Lixianermittel nehmen, damit ich keinen Splack-Anfall bekomme.
Okay.
Haben Sie immer noch bescheiden, ja?
Ja.
Okay.
Das wird sich wohl auch nicht mehr ändern.
Das muss ich jetzt immer weiter nehmen, dieses Medikament.
Okay, dann verstehe ich.
Und Herr Gutmann, rauchen Sie?
Nein, ich rauche nicht.
Und zinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ich trinke so ein Glas Wein pro Tag.
Und bitte meine folgende Frage, bitte nehmen Sie nicht, weiß ich.
Das ist nur eine Rutzener Frage.
Die Drogen?
Nein, ich nehme keine Drogen.
Okay, gut.
Darf ich fragen, Leben ist wieder als ein Hoch?
Nein, der Vater ist im Alter von 72 Jahren an Darmkrebs verstorben.
Und er hatte Darmkrebs, ja.
Und die Mutter, die lebt, ist 84 Jahre alt.
Nein, die ist nicht 84, aber 94 ist sie.
94 Jahre.
Und die hat eine Herzmuskelschwäche.
Also ihr Herz ist ziemlich schwach, schon seit einigen Jahren.
Da muss sie auch viele Medikamente nehmen.
Und ja, sie kann sich kaum mehr bewegen.
Ich habe noch einen Bruder, der ist 65 Jahre alt, der hat auch hohen Blutdruck.
Und haben Sie sich verheiratet?
Nein, ich bin nicht verheiratet.
Okay, leben wir allein?
Ja, ich lebe alleine.
Also haben Sie Kinder?
Nein.
Und waren Sie ins Dief von Beirgus?
Ich war Straßenbauer, in der Straßenbau tätig.
Okay.
Und jetzt möchte ich Ihre aktuelle Beschwerden zurückkommen.
Sie haben eine Bauchschmeißung, linkseite, jetzt ganzer Bauch.
Ja.
Und sind Ihnen in Ihrer Haut zum Beispiel eine blaue Flöcke aufgefallen?
Nein, auf meiner Haut ist mir nichts aufgefallen.
Nein.
Okay, dann, Herr Gutmann, ich habe alle wichtige Informationen notiert.
Möchtest Sie fragen oder möchte Sie etwas ergänzen?
Ja, was kann das sein?
Ich mache mir große Sorgen, weil solche Schmerzen habe ich noch nie gehabt,
die so plötzlich begonnen haben auch.
Und ich kann mir überhaupt gar keine Erklärung geben, was da los ist.
Ja, vor der Untersuchung, leider kann ich nicht viel sagen.
Also ich möchte, so heißt es, die körperlich ausführliche Untersuchung
und danach meine Blut abnehmen.
Ich werde ein paar weitere Untersuchungen durchführen,
zum Beispiel Bauch und Verschall.
Und wenn alle Ergebnisse vorliegen, können wir eine sichere Diagnose stellen
und danach mit Ihnen nochmal bespielen.
Okay, das können wir so machen.
Gut.
Okay, und noch ein paar Sachen.
Ja, ja.
Warum sind es Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Also ich, das Wasserlassen ist eigentlich in Ordnung.
Ich muss nachts zweimal auf Toilette Wasser lassen.
Das hängt ein bisschen davon ab, ob ich abends jetzt mehr Tee
oder Wassertränke noch.
Ich war aber schon mal beim Orologen und er hat gesagt,
ja, die Prosta da ist leicht vergrößert.
Aber wenn ich sonst keine Beschwerden habe, braucht man erst mal nichts machen.
Ich muss noch auch wieder gut einschlafen.
Insofern stört mich das nicht.
Okay, danke schön.
Danke schön.
Dann haben Sie jetzt etwas Zeit, sich vorzubereiten.
Ich denke, ein, zwei Fragen sind noch zu beantworten,
die auch nicht gestellt worden sind.
Wenn Kollegen da vielleicht Fragen haben oder das ergänzen wollen,
können wir das jetzt gerne tun?
Ja, ich habe eine Frage.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie zweimal Erbrochen haben.
Ja.
Wie sagt die Erbrochen aus?
Das Erbrochen war so gelblich, gelblich wässrig.
Gelblich wässrig.
Okay, haben Sie Blut bemerkt?
Nein, Blut, blutig sah das nicht aus.
Okay, danke schön.
Okay.
Es gibt noch eine wichtige Frage, die so noch nicht gestellt wurde.
Haben Sie Ihre Medikamente legtianer regelmäßig eingenommen?
Ja, legtianer, das habe ich alles regelmäßig eingenommen.
Ja, da mache ich mir einmal in der Woche so eine Übersicht
in so einer Dosette heißt das und dann mache ich das ganz regelmäßig.
Ja.
Gibt es bemerkt?
Haben Sie gegen diese Schmerzen
vielleicht Medikamente eingenommen?
Nein, bis jetzt nicht.
Ich habe gehört von meinem Nachbarn,
dass wenn ich jetzt Schmerzmittel nehme und dann ins Krankenhaus gehe,
dass das Bild verändert und das wäre nicht gut, ich soll mal abwarten.
Ich wurde ja von der Ärztin auch gefragt, ob ich jetzt ein Medikament brauche.
Im Augenblick nicht, wenn es nicht so lange dauert jetzt mit den Untersuchungen.
Aber eine Frage ist noch nicht gestellt worden.
Ja, darf ich fragen?
Ja.
Hatten Sie bisher eine Vorsorge-Darm-Spiegelung?
Und falls ja, wie war die Ergebnis?
Ja, ich hatte eine Vorsorge-Darm-Spiegelung, da war ich glaube ich 60 Jahre alt,
weil es damals auch hieß, weil mein Vater am Darmkrebs verstorben ist.
Ich soll das machen lassen.
Das war in Ordnung, die Vorsorge-Darm-Spiegelung war gut.
Habt ihr gefragt, oder?
Nach Darm-Spiegelung wurde glaube ich nicht gefragt.
Aber eine Frage wurde glaube ich noch nicht gestellt nach Voroperationen.
Ja, Voroperation.
Ja, sagte Herr Grundmann, ich bin operiert worden.
Als Kind hatte ich einen...
Aber ich habe schon gefragt.
Sie haben nur gesagt bei der Katheter, bei dieser Operation mit dem Katheter haben Sie gefragt.
Aber weitere Operationen haben Sie nicht gefragt.
Kollegen haben es gefragt, aber Sie haben Katheter ersellt und dann nicht...
Vielleicht ist es vergessen worden.
Also jedenfalls als Kind wurde ich Herr Grundmann wegen einem Nabelbruch operiert.
Und im Alter von 30 Jahren, als ich 30 Jahre alt war,
da hatte ich eine Messerstichverletzung im Bauch.
Und das war ziemlich schwierig.
Da wurde mir in einer Notoperation die Hand erkannt.
Und es wurde ein Teil des Dickdames entfernt.
Da hatte ich zwei Stiche im Oberbauch auf der linken Seite.
Und da wurde der Dickdamp verletzt und die Milz.
Und da musste die Milz entfernt werden und ein Teil vom Dickdamp wurde entfernt.
Da war ich 30 Jahre alt.
Ja, okay.
Die Frage nach Impfungen.
Impfungen sollt man natürlich noch stellen.
Ja, ich war im letzten Jahr, war ich beim Hausarzt.
Und wegen dem Blutdruck und dem Blutfetten und so.
Und da hat er aber gesagt, meine Impfungen sind gut.
Ich muss in diesem Herbst wieder eine Grippeimpfung machen und eine Covid-Impfung.
Das wollte ich jetzt im November machen.
Auslöser gibt es bestimmt auch auslöser für die Schmerzen.
Haben Sie bemerkt?
Auslöser für die Schmerzen kenne ich nicht.
Der Schmerz war plötzlich da.
Aber Sie haben gesagt, langsam sind aufgetreten.
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Der Schmerz war plötzlich da, aber er wurde dann immer schlimmer.
Er war mit einem Schlachttartes weh, aber noch nicht so stark wie jetzt.
Dann wurden die Schmerzen immer schlimmer.
Aber er begann ziemlich plötzlich.
Sie haben gesagt, seit zwei Tagen keine Sturrgank.
Aber Gas, die gehen ab.
Ich denke, alle Fragen gestellt.
Eine Frage bitte.
Ich habe nicht gut gehört.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig Blutverdünnung Medikamente ein?
Ja, ich nehme ein Medikament ein.
Das ist ein Medikament, das liegt an.
Regeln Sie regelmäßig?
Ja, regelmäßig, jeden Tag.
Vielen Dank.
Können wir erst mal die Sprache anfangen?
Von mir aus gerne.
Ja, okay.
Ja, können wir anfangen.
Guten Abend, Herr Oberleih.
Ich möchte Ihnen gerne den Patienten Herr Grutmann vorstellen.
Er ist 67 Jahre alt, 1,84 Meter groß und 6,90 kg schwer.
Er hat sich vor der Ausgrunde von seit zwei Tagen bestehend ein Halt- und langsam begonnenen Abdominär geschmert.
Ich berichtete, dass ich meistens beginnst auf der linken Seite,
aber dann breitere, da schmerz ich auf den Gesamtstand auch aus.
Wir haben das eben besprochen, die Schmerzen waren nicht ganz langsam ansteigend,
sondern plötzlich waren Schmerzen da, aber nicht so stark wie jetzt.
Okay.
Haben Sie die Schmerzkala den Patienten abgefragt?
Welche Stärke die Schmerzen haben?
Ja, diese Schmerzen wurden mit 7 bis 8 angestuft.
7 bis 8?
Ja.
Okay.
Anfangs waren die Schmerzen vielleicht 5, aber sie waren plötzlich da,
und dann bauten sich immer stärker jetzt auf.
Welche Charakter haben die Schmerzen?
Diese Schmerzen sind dunkel und kranzweiß.
Okay.
Gut.
Ja.
Er klackte über Neusea, und der Patient musste sich zweimal übergeben.
Ja, kennen Sie das Wort für Erbrechen?
Ermesis.
Okay.
Zweimalige Emesis, ja.
Und wie sagt es Erbrochene aus?
Ja, die Erbrochen sieht gelblich und wässrig.
Gelblich und wässrig, also kein Blut.
Okay.
Ja.
Ja, die vegetative Anamnese bis auf Schmerzbedingte in Sonja war unabhängig.
Okay.
Und der Patient hat keine Allergie.
Und Anvorerkrankungen sind arterial Hikar-Toni seit 8 Jahren,
die Prälipidemie seit 5 Jahren und Arithmi seit 3 Jahren bekannt.
Arithmi, Arithmi des Herzens.
Ja.
Und Anvor-Operationen sindforener Angiografie und um die Herr-Härmien-Operation.
Ja, sagen Sie bitte, dass chronologisch.
Im Kindesamt.
Okay.
Ja.
In der Kindheit.
Um die Herr-Härmien-Operation.
Okay.
Und im Alter vom Drei-Sin wählt eine Messer.
Schittig-Ferletzpunkt.
Ja, gut.
Eine, also, Milz-Einz-Verletzung.
Ja, kennen Sie den Fachberiff?
Milz-Ektomie.
Ja, kann ein Kollege helfen?
Ja.
Wie heißt die Milz-Entfernung an die Kollegen?
Spleenektomie.
Spleenektomie, ja.
Als erfolgte aufgrund einer Messer-Stich-Verletzung eine Spleenektomie.
Und was wurde noch operiert?
Und Teil-Kolektomie.
Ja, oder man kann sagen eine Kolon-Teil-Resektion.
Ja.
Teil-Resektion oder Teil-Resektion des Kolons.
Wahrscheinlich war es im Bereich der linken Flexur.
Gehe ich mal von aus, wenn dort der Messer-Stich war, der hat dann die Milz-Verletzt.
Und er hat wahrscheinlich im Bereich der linken Flexur das Kolon-Verletzt.
Eine Kolon-Teil-Resektion.
Okay, das war im Alter von 30 Jahren.
Und vor drei Jahren war dann die Corona-Angiografie wahrscheinlich eine Katheter-Aplation.
Ja.
Aber diese Katheter-Aplation war nicht erfolgreich.
Okay, was für Medikamente nimmt der Patient ein?
Er nimmt Kandiesalzen, 8 Milligramm, Morgen und Abend.
Ja.
Isoprolor für Milligramm, Morgen und Abend.
Genachpatienten 20 Milligramm, Abend.
Lexianer, 16 Milligramm.
60, 60.
Lexianer gibt es als 30 Milligramm und als 60 Milligramm Tablette und 60.
Jetzt die normale Dosis für Erwachsene.
Morgen und Abend.
Ein, ja, das war das.
Gut.
Der Patient ruft nichts.
Und Alkoholkonsum ist gelänglich.
Einglas Wein pro Tag.
Also nein, regelmäßig.
Er bringt Einglas Wein pro Tag.
Ja.
Gibt es Auffälligkeiten in der Familienanamnese?
Der Vater ist, der Vater ist, der Vater und die Mutter sind verstorben.
Also der Vater ist verstorben in welchem Alter?
72.
Mit 72 Jahren ist der Vater, woran verstorben?
An Kolonkastinau.
Genau, ja.
Und die Mutter ist mit 94.
Er heißt Insuffizienz verstorben.
Ja, Herzinsuffizienz oder Myokartinsuffizienz, ja.
Gut.
Gibt es Geschwister?
Der Bruder ist 560 und er leidet am RZ 11.
Okay.
Gut.
Was ist denn Ihre Verdachtstiagnose?
Also ich, ehrlich gesagt, ich weiß es nicht.
Es ist schwierig, glaube ich, weil, denken Sie mal
über die sogenannten Red Flags.
Die Schmerzen begannen, das haben wir korrigiert, die Schmerzen begannen relativ plötzlich.
Sie war nicht so ganz langsam angefangen, sondern sie begannen relativ plötzlich.
Da hat der Bauch weh, links umbilikal, also im linken Mittelbauch mehr,
aber dann der Schmerz im gesamten Abdomen, krampfartig, teilweise aber dumpf,
nicht wellenförmig.
Da würden wir ein etwas anderes vielleicht denken.
Und der Patient hat als nächste Red Flag Herzrhythmusstörungen,
persistierende Herzrhythmusstörungen, wahrscheinlich bei absoluter Arithmie und Vorflimmern.
Der Patient nimmt verschiedene Medikamente als Risikofaktor, die atelle Hypatonie,
die Hypercholesterinämie und das persistierende Vorflimmern oder die Herzrhythmusstörung.
Und er hat einen voroperierten Bauch, zweimalig voroperiert, einmal die Nabel,
die umbilikalheranie, aber was vielleicht schwieriger ist,
die Messerstichverletzung, die Splenectomy und die Kolontaresektion.
Wenn der Schmerz jetzt vielleicht wellenförmig wäre, dann würden Sie wahrscheinlich
ein Einkrankheitsbild eher denken, vielleicht ein Ilius.
Ein Ilius ist ja häufig, wenn es nicht gerade ein paralytischer Ilius ist,
ist es wellenförmige Bild.
Ich habe Ihnen heute ein etwas schwieriger Fall ausgesucht, das stimme ich zu.
Ich würde die Verdachtstiagnose bei dieser Sache stellen, an eine akuten Mesinterialinfarkt,
an eine Emboly im gastrointestinalen Bereich,
Arteria, Mesintherica, Inferior oder was auch immer.
Wenn dort ein Embolus ist, gibt das einen akuten Schmerz erstmal.
Der muss jetzt nicht gleich in der Skala 8 oder 9 sein,
aber dann entwickelt sich daraufhin ein akutes Abdomen.
Dann tut alles weh aufgrund der kardialen Anamnese.
Trotz Lyxiana kann das passieren, dass ein Embolus sich löst.
Vielleicht hat der Patient vergessen zu erwähnen, ja, der Kardiologe hat beim letzten Mal gesagt,
da ist sogar ein Gerinsel in ihrem Herzen, einem linken Vorhof
und wir müssen auf alle Fälle Lyxiana geben, damit sie nicht eine Emboly bekommen,
aber er ist ein Hochrisikopatient.
Ja, aber in Karserir-Tehernin, oder Briden, Koprosoase, Tümöl, Tümöl,
Bridenilius kann auch nach 30 Jahren noch passieren, ein voroperierten Bauch.
Aber das muss man natürlich abklären.
Es geht jetzt auch nicht darum, dass die Kollegin eine richtige Diagnose stellt
aufgrund dieser Befragung.
Deswegen müssen sie nicht verzweifeln.
Es wurde unten auch die Frage gestellt, Ilius.
Ich habe bewusst gesagt, die Schmerzen sind nicht wellenförmig.
Oft haben wir ja beim Ilius, dass es wirklich dieses typisch wellenförmige ist,
wenn es ein mechanischer Ilius ist, was natürlich passieren kann.
Aber das müssen sie ja alles abklären jetzt im Krankenhaus.
Der Patient muss stationär aufgenommen werden und er muss nüchtern bleiben.
Wahrscheinlich muss man jetzt als nächstes eine Sonografie machen,
eine Computertomographie.
Aber man muss natürlich auch sehen, dass wenn man den Verdacht auf eine Emboly hat,
dass man das Gewebe, was jetzt nicht mehr durchblutet wird,
das möglichst schnell vielleicht retten kann.
Also er ist sicherlich ein absoluter Notfall dieser Patient.
Gut, ja, das war jetzt etwas schwierig.
Das gebe ich zu.
Aber manchmal sind es auch die etwas schwierigen Fälle, die weiterführen.
Aber ich finde, das haben Sie gut gemacht.
Sie haben klare Fragen gestellt.
Vergessen Sie bitte nicht die Operationen.
Das war mir nicht so ganz klar als Patient.
Sie hatten mich nach der Tat wieder gefragt.
Fragen Sie ruhig, sind Sie sonst schon mal operiert worden in Ihrem Leben?
Ja, oder gibt es weitere Operationen?
Das sind, denke ich, wichtige Fragen, die dürfen nicht vergessen werden.
Zumindest kann es sein, dass dann der Oberarzt oder die Oberjahrsinn das fragt.
Gerade wenn jemand so akut Bauchmärzen hat,
dann fragt der Chirurg sofort, gibt es im Bauch vor Operationen.
Und wenn es eine Blind-up-Operation, eine Appendectomie ist,
das ist auch eine Voroperation.
Klar.
Vielen Dank.
Ich konnte Sie sehr gut verstehen.
Sie haben sich gut ausgedrückt.
Alles gut.